So now what we'd
like to do is try
to understand how to apply the
law of addition of velocities.
So we can express the
velocity of the point
on the rim in the reference
frame fixed to the ground.
Now, the important
thing to realize
is v is the velocity
of the center of mass
of the wheel with
respect to the ground,
and every single point on the
wheel has that same velocity v.
So let's draw a
picture of our wheel.
Here we're in the
ground reference frame.
And let's first draw
four points on the wheel
and draw this velocity v. Every
single one of these points
has the same velocity
v, v, v, and v.
Now, let's add to
that the velocity
of a point on the rim as
seen in the reference frame
moving with the center of mass.
We just saw that every
single point on the wheel
is undergoing circular motion
in that reference frame.
So now let's draw
those velocities.
I'll just draw it right below--
vcmp, down here vcmp.
Notice here it's in the
opposite direction, vcmp,
and up here it's pointing up.
So when we add these two
vectors together, what we get
is a longer vector
in this direction.
It would be the sum
of these two pieces.
So it would point like that.
That's vp.
Over here it's the
vector decomposition.
So it's in that direction.
Here it's a shorter vector vp.
And over here it's
the vector sum vp.
So now what we've
been able to do
is describe the
velocity of the point p
as a combination,
the vector addition,
of how the center of mass
of the wheel is moving
and the circular motion as seen
in a reference frame moving
with the center of mass.
Now what we want to explore
is special conditions,
which we'll refer to as rolling
without slipping, slipping,
or sliding.